cette vidéo est sponsorisée par olsker
avec plus d'un million de clients
uniques holskern c'est le site
spécialisé en accessoires de luxe montre
bijouterie bandelette lunettes de soleil
le tout avec des matériaux originaux
nacre bois pierre et bien plus encore
waouh vous avez une montre en fromage
oui bien sûr et quelle heure est-il et
bien d'après maman montre il est miska
[Musique]
pour elle offrez lui ce magnifique petit
sac à main à Samir en ardoise noir avec
une finition brillante du plus bel effet
qui lui permettra de ranger tous ces
petits effets personnels féminins
pour lui aidez-le à ne pas perdre le fil
de sa journée avec cette splendide
montre folle morning en bois de Zebra
wood and wingué qui sera son compagnon
indispensable pour garder le temps dans
la course contre la montre qui
ça donne l'heure aussi avec plus de 800
modèles différents vous êtes sûr de
trouver un modèle unique qui vous
correspondra holscare visitez le site
avec le lien en description
[Musique]
et bien les amis qui auraient pu croire
que le mystérieux fantôme vert était en
réalité le patron du parc d'attraction
qui voulait faire fermer l'endroit pour
construire un parking par dessus
et du coup les amis où est-ce qu'on va
maintenant mon oncle les propriétaires
d'un musée dans une petite ville pas
loin d'ici un peu de culture fera le
plus grand bien vos cerveaux limité
et puis de toute façon nous n'irons pas
plus loin la mystérie machine n'a plus
d'essence bah si tout va bien on a
encore un bidon d'essence à l'arrière on
avait un bison licence si seulement le
prix des sens n'avait pas explosé à
cause des mesures aussi du gouvernement
[Musique]
attendez une seconde vous ne trouvez pas
qu'il y a quelque chose de bizarre oui
c'est très étrange ce musée a l'air
fermé oui c'est parce qu'on est dimanche
ce n'est pas normal il doit y avoir un
mystère là dessous il est 23h tout est
fermé à cette heure-ci c'est marqué sur
le panneau
vous pouvez dire qu'il y a des bonbons
des fantômes
j'ai trouvé le gardien du musée monsieur
pourquoi votre musée il est fermé et
bien parce qu'on est dimanche qu'il est
23h et tout est marqué sur le panneau là
on risque pas d'ouvrir d'ici de moi ou
ça à cause de la momie du musée
c'est vous qui
voulez vous avez le contrat qui dépasse
de votre poche vous avez une bandelette
blanche accrochée à votre chaussure et
cette momie n'est pas une momie c'est à
Hachette est-ce que quelqu'un peut me
ramener à la maison voilà la police est
déjà là pour vous arrêter bonne soirée
est-ce qu'on peut partir maintenant je
commence à dessouder bien joué vera
voilà le nouveau conservateur du musée
[Musique]
de moi tout ça à cause du fantôme du
musée
[Applaudissements]
il est là
tu l'entends
[Musique]
vous êtes la raison pour laquelle je me
suis mise à boire les amis séparons-nous
pour trouver des indices
dans les années 60 anaé Barbera
propriétaire des studios Hannah Barbera
connu pour les Pierrafeu se retrouvent
sous le feu de critiques pour leur
dernier dessin animé le fantôme de
l'espace jugé trop violent pour combler
le trou dans la grille de leur programme
CBS leur donnant alors de concevoir une
nouvelle série le concept qui s'appelle
alors misteries five meté en scène 5
adolescents Joffre Mike Kelly Linda et
double you doble sont frère ainsi que
leur chien tout much tous membres d'un
groupe de rock resolvant entre deux
concerts des mystères impliquant
fantômes zombies et autres créatures
surnaturelles pour le chien et les
créateurs hésitent entre petit chien
courageux ou un gros chien peureux et
c'est finalement la deuxième option qui
sera retenue bien que l'idée du petit
chien courageux a été recyclé plus tard
car la série fut en perte de vitesse
avec le personnage de scrapidou le choix
du chien lui fut porté sur un grand
danois histoire d’éviter une trop grande
ressemblance avec la série archi dans
lequel figurer déjà un Bobtail le
concept de la série fut encore
retravaillé les personnages de Jeff et
Mike furent fusionné en un seul
rebaptisé Fred Kelly furné Daphné Linda
vera et enfin double you le frère de
Daphné à la base fut changé en famille
l'ambiance globale de la série jugé trop
effrayante fut adoucie pour être rendu
plus comique l'idée du groupe de rock
abandonnée la tension davantage portée
sur Sammy et son chien et le chien en
question too much fut rebaptisé
scoubidou en référence à la chanson
stranger in the night de Frank Sinatra
la série scoubidou était né et la vache
Scooby-Doo c'est vraiment une de ces
séries impossible à tuer et bordel de
merde pourtant il y en a qui ont essayé
fort
et même si c'est un peu passé en second
plan pendant les années 90 malgré
quelques émissions qui continuaient à
diffuser ça comme Anna Barbera dingue
donc sur France 2 présenté par Lucas met
bonjour les dingues ah les années 90
l'époque où les émissions avaient des
présentateurs humains ça avait une âme
les
Vanina viendra
inards
viendra du Sud là-haut à la blague c'est
que c'est une femme
du coup bah elle est conne
en temps normal je serai horrifié mais
vu qu'on est en 1993 tout va bien
ouais bon après c'est comme pour tout
des fois t'as pas de chance tu tombes
sur un mauvais extrait
ok pitié stop bref après une décennie 90
un peu creuse là franchise a connu une
remontée de hype phénoménale au début
des années 2000 avec l'excellente
nouvelle série quoi de neuf Scooby-Doo
plusieurs jeux vidéo et bien sûr les
films
[Musique]
merde les gens vont encore dire que tu
es grise tu trouves pas ça drôle
bien joué
niveau jeux vidéo alors que tous les
ingrédients étaient là avant la majorité
des jeux Scooby-Doo se situe dans la
période du renouveau poste de mille mais
évidemment avant d'avoir eu ça
[Musique]
il y a d'abord eu ça
le tout premier jeu scoubidou de
l'histoire
j'adore le thème classique de la série
là scoubidou
ta mère dans ce jeu on joue
scoubidou je
oui là à droite je crois que c'est lui
au moins que ce soit un étourneau qui
est chié sur mon écran je sais pas et
c'est exactement comme un Pacman mais
inversé vu qu'ici c'est nous qui devons
poursuivre les fantômes et les tuer bien
sûr le fameux scoubidou le chien de
chasse aux énormes couilles viril les
poilus qui pourchassent les fantômes et
c'est bien vous avez bien regardé la
série bon alors évidemment vu l'âge du
jeu vont vous emboutez bien j'ai pas
grand chose à en dire tout va bien ouais
aucun problème là non mais vraiment je
pense qu'on peut dire que ce jeu est un
sens ah oui d'ailleurs un petit détail
sachez que pour jouer à ce jeu il
fallait obligatoirement l'adaptateur
clavier de la télévision pour jouer à un
Packman clavier qui a coûté 400 balles
pour jouer à du Pacman
il y avait pas assez de boutons de base
là dessus là bref à part un jeu
scoubidou insupportable sur ZX Spectrum
où le seul défi c'est de savoir combien
de temps vous allez supporter ça avant
d'y [ __ ] le feu et un jeu scrapidou de
plateforme dans la musique ressemble un
vieux qui gêne warrez by Razer 1911 très
rapidement les jeux Scooby-Doo ont
laissé tomber l'idée de jouer Scooby
pour se concentrer sur Sammy qui offrait
plus de possibilités et c'est
logiquement les punt and clicks qui
semblaient être la recette la plus
évidente pour un jeu mettant en scène un
groupe de gens qui résolvent des
enquêtes je vous en aurais bien parlé
mais malheureusement je n'ai plus
d'argent pour acheter ces jeux là parce
qu'à la place je suis
claque man ouh je suis un rétro gamer oh
il faudra attendre la version Super NES
pour avoir une première variation de
gameplay avec scoubidou mystery on reste
dans un genre assez proche du point and
click puisque le jeu vous demandera
surtout de récupérer des indices
dispersés à travers les niveaux pour
prouver que la créature qui hante chaque
lieu est en réalité non pas un fantôme
ou un monstre mais un type dans un
déguisement ah là c'est sûr que niveau
fidélité là le jeu respecte la série
c'est parfaitement con exactement pareil
genre dans le niveau 2 tu te fais
poursuivre par un clone donc tu cherches
des indices pour les ramener à Vera et
voilà la tête des indices un nez rouge
des grosses chaussures de clown un
masque de clown les amis je pense que ce
clown est en réalité un petit pas
déguisé en clown
heureusement t'es là c'est super verra
dans ce jeu pas de barre de vie à la
place on a donc une barre de peur qui
monte lorsque les ennemis votent et qui
lorsqu'elle arrive à 100%, vous fait
recommencer la salle en cours ouais
parce que contrairement à un vrai point
le jeu a quand même rajouté quelques
ennemis sur le trajet histoire que vous
finissiez pas tout ça en une heure et le
jeu serait tout mignon si les ennemis ne
remplissaient pas ta barbe de peur en
deux secondes oh regardez je l'ai même
pas touché j'ai quand même pris les
dégâts [ __ ] ça sent encore la bonne
équipe bien concentrée sur ce qu'elle
faisait encore avant développer un
programme c'était difficile avec un
clavier classique je ne pouvais pas
correctement atteindre les touches
latérales
mais maintenant le clavier souple me
permet d'épouser complètement la forme
de ma tête en atteignant ainsi 100% des
touches ce qui me permet de foirer
jusqu'à 97% de mon code en un seul
passage plus jamais je ne reviendrai en
arrière
ah c'est pas grave c'est que le début du
test on va pas s'énerver pour si
et l'autre problème chiant de ce jeu
c'est qu'il n'y a aucun temps d'in
vulnérabilité entre deux coups et qu'en
prime certains ennemis de One Shot
[Musique]
de la vie en demandant des scoubidous à
cadavné mais pas avant d'avoir progressé
dans le tricks de chaque salle [ __ ]
non on n'ira pas à l'hôpital tant que tu
n'auras pas avancé dans l'enquête chaque
niveau se finit et c'est assez
sympathique pour le signaler comme dans
le dessin animé par Fred qui fait un
piège pour capturer le fantôme ok les
amis le fantôme est déjà piégé dans la
glue il peut plus bouger je pense que
c'est pas utile de lui tirer ce boulet
de canon dans la tête là qu'est-ce que
tu fais ça arrête ça tout de suite non
et voilà les amis encore une belle
affaire de régler et maintenant tout le
monde pense à si
on aura un peu dans le même genre un
autre jeu Scooby-Doo cette fois sur
Nintendo 64 le jeu reprend le même
système et nous emmène affronter
quelques-uns des ennemis emblématiques
de la série scoubidou comme le chevalier
noir dans un niveau 1 qui semble
clairement être le musée d'histoire
naturelle le moins sécurisé du monde et
donc ici les enfants nous sommes dans la
salle du diplodocus un dinosaure apparu
[ __ ] Enzo on a dit on tousse pas les
statues vous allez donc devoir trouver
des indices dispersés pour finir chaque
niveau et le jeu est plutôt généreux
voilà c'est tranquille vous pouvez
vraiment vous faire attraper 15 fois
d'affilée par le garde du musée il se
contentera de vous mettre une petite
table sur les fesses avant de vous
montrer la sortie sans jamais de Game
Over ouais mais heureusement que c'est
pas le Samy de la nouvelle série ah
désolé monsieur le gardien de musée je
pensais que
bref pas grand chose à en dire si ce
n'est que les changements de caméra
foutent régulièrement les contrôler et
que Scooby a tendance à se [ __ ] tout
le temps dans tes pieds quand tu as
besoin de fuite [ __ ] le chien en gros
pas forcément des chefs mais en tout cas
des jeux plutôt corrects du coup on me
dit que ça se voit horriblement agaçante
là j'ai trouvé un article de journal
d'attendre il y a deux ans disant que le
directeur du musée était en discussion
pour construire un parking d'attraction
dans une grande surface
[Musique]
très drôle
Batman
et bien j'espère que Samy et scoubidou
s'en sortent mieux que nous
regarde scoubidou j'ai trouvé de vrais
trésors un bout de jambon à peine entamé
une approche de pas moisi juste comme il
faut
un tampon usagé
un article de jeu vidéo.com enfin bon
c'est pas grave avec tout ça on va se
régaler je crois que j'ai une mauvaise
affluence surtout
[Musique]
respire dis-moi ce que tu as à dire
il y a un fantôme dans le couloir
[Musique]
attendez-moi les copains j'arrive
tu vas te calmer oui
tafs le droit de faire ça écoutez les
amis il faut capturer ce fantôme et pour
ça il nous faut un plan laissez-moi
réfléchir
scoubidou and the cyber shades un jeu
vidéo tiré du film du même nom sorti en
2002 2002 l'époque de la PlayStation 2
de la GameCube de jeux excellent comme
Mario Sunshine Splinter Cell Medal of
Honor Kingdom heart enfin on va
peut-être jouer à un bon jeu
[Musique]
dans ce jeu scoubidou et le Scooby Gang
sont donc aspirés dans un jeu vidéo
parole cybers spermatozoïde qui a
répondu son virus à travers tout le jeu
comme nous explique la cinématique
je ne sais pas pourquoi les personnages
marquent des pauses énormes entre chaque
réplique
ce qui je dois avouer donne à cette
intro certains passages plutôt comique
[Musique]
ok donc penchons-nous sur le gameplay il
va donc falloir chercher le virus dans
chaque monde et chaque niveau va se
passer dans un jeu vidéo différent comme
le Japon l'Italie l'Egypte et le via
vous connaissez pas le célèbre jeu vidéo
Japon bon mon préféré c'est super Japon
3 le premier niveau se déroule donc dans
ok d'accord merci de m'interrompre
absolument pour rien ça super merci
beaucoup donc je disais que le premier
niveau se oh
ok
sérieusement donc en fait donc quand on
joue à ce jeu on se rend compte qu'ils
ont voulu ta mère j'ai eu le temps de
faire quatre mètres quoi encore
qu'est-ce qu'il y a aussi
c'est bon j'appuie sur X pour sauter là
je suis pas débile arrêtez de
m'interrompre tout le temps j'ai
l'impression que je joue à God of War
Ragnarok
je vous jure que je vais péter un plomb
j'ai fait 10 mètres depuis le début du
niveau
regardez ça en version accélérée ce jeu
parle donc
ta gueule j'ai des flèches de Bugzy là
le moindre élément de gameplay et je dis
bien le moindre
micro-éléments de gameplay donne lieu à
un tuto même si le truc est archi
évident
e
merci Fred devait me jeter dessus et
être noyé de fenêtre de tuto c'est
d'autant plus énervant que le jeu est
archi facile
ah [ __ ] ah merci du conseil Daphné on
a eu chaud et attention ne vous dites
pas que c'est juste pour le premier
niveau
parce que c'est le niveau 8 et ça
continue
[Musique]
d'accord c'est super Daphné i au fait je
me masturbe sur ton visage quand tu dors
Daphné oh non mais [ __ ] je suis désolé
mais là vraiment moi ça me fait péter un
plomb [ __ ] même le chien me donne des
conseils ou alors quoi c'est parce que
c'est Sami tout le monde pense qu'il est
débile c'est est-ce que tout le monde
est aussi condescendant que ça tout le
temps avec lui
Samy tu prends bien le petit papy rose
pour essuyer le caca du cucul hein et
vous savez ce qui m'énerve c'est que
chaque fois que vous ramassez une seule
[ __ ] de tarte à la crème vous avez ce
bruitage
[Musique]
bref on a enfin passé les premiers tutos
on va enfin pouvoir profiter du jeu
[Musique]
oh mon dieu c'est chiant alors donc au
bout de 2 secondes de jeu on comprend
clairement qu'ils ont essayé de faire
une photocopie de Crash Bandicoot et
quand je dis photocopie c'est pas une
exagération ils ont même pas cherché à
faire semblant genre le lobby de
sélection des niveaux c'est le même
voilà en fait tu as l'impression que
toute la création du jeu entier elle a
commencé comme ça elle est gâché une
idée on va tout copier sur les autres et
en plus on va mal le faire et du coup
quand on commence à comparer avec un
crash Bandicoot c'est terrible c'est
tout le jeu est tellement mou aucun
ennemi ne pose la moindre menace aucun
piège n'est dangereux vous pouvez juste
esquiver tout le monde et pisser sur le
jeu ah je viens de gagner contre le boss
final du niveau 1 du 1er coup en ayant
joué mais complètement comme un cul et
d'ailleurs en vérité le jeu est
tellement facile que je pense vraiment
que je pourrais essayer de jouer avec
[Musique]
chaque niveau vous demandera donc
simplement d'avancer jusqu'au bout de
récupérer le sachet de Scooby crack et
hop c'est fini voilà c'est absolument la
seule raison d'aller jusqu'à la fin des
niveaux enfin ça et la petite gigue de
Scoubidou là
[Musique]
parce que c'est clairement pas pour les
graphismes qu'on reste là
à partir du niveau 2 on va bien jouer de
temps en temps avec Sami qui se contrôle
de la même façon que Scooby à la
différence que lui peut ramper ce qui
est vachement utile pour que dalle vu
que ça ne sert quasi jamais dans le jeu
le jeu avec famille est sensiblement le
même à part parfois quelques variations
de gameplay avec un Sami qui a l'air de
beaucoup plus s'amuser que nous hein
clairement vu la lenteur de la luge
ça
va trop vite on va plus vite que la
galaxie nous sommes que des particules
de l'univers
bref des niveaux un petit peu énervant à
cause de la lenteur des contrôles mais
quand même on a vu cinq fois pire je
dirais que sur une échelle de douleur on
est sur le petit bonhomme vert avec les
sourcils horizontaux
salut c'est Joueur du Grenier vous vous
souvenez quand j'ai dit que le jeu était
trop facile
on va revenir sur la déclaration ok
alors soyons clairs les sauts de ce jeu
sont un peu à vomir alors c'est pas à
vomir genre la grosse flaque sur le mur
c'est plutôt à vomir du genre vous savez
le petit renvoi acide qui reste coincé
dans la gorge là c'est très imagé je
sais bref c'est dur à comprendre sans
avoir la même quand même mais jusque là
j'avais rien dit parce que c'était pas
le centre du gameplay et surtout il y en
avait pas énormément mais à la fin il y
a des sauts
partout mon dieu c'est même plus qui est
les niveaux sont remplis de sauce et
jusque il y a même plus de niveau en
fait il y a juste des sauts il y a plus
que ça c'est nul tu as de la merde dans
les mains de la merde dans les yeux
c'est dégueulasse et les ennemis c'est
juste
quoi chaque année des centaines de
personnes restent bloquées à vie en
pratiquant un spin ne laissez pas vos
enfants tomber là dedans le hip-hop les
victimes en parle alors en fait le
Mexique et tu vas péter dans mon
réfrigérateur
[Musique]
et pour finir en plus de la merde dans
les oreilles parce que tous les derniers
niveaux se font sur un espèce de fond de
musique de baise
alors que la seule personne qui se fait
baiser ici c'est moi quant au boss final
c'est n'importe quoi regardez la vitesse
du boss par rapport à la vitesse de mon
perso
bébé qui tousse
le boss va littéralement cinq fois plus
vite que moi alors j'ai cherché partout
je suis allé sur des forums sous des
vidéos et tous les gens le disent il n'y
a aucune strat la seule chose à faire
c'est de tourner en rond en priant pour
un miracle et si éventuellement vous
arrivez à le battre grâce à beaucoup de
chance et quelques save state sur
emulateur aussi on va pas se mentir vous
retrouvez Fred vera et Daphné qui vous
disent qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé de piège
pour capturer le fantôme mais que Fred
s'est souvenu qu'il avait eu une grosse
manette avec un petit bouton sur
lesquels il est marqué antivirus pour le
tuer d'un seul coup
et dire que j'avais ça sur moi depuis le
début
et du coup si on veut des bons jeux
scoubidous et bien il faudra jouer sur
la génération suivante comme Scooby-Doo
la nuit des sans frissons sortis sur
Playstation 2 est sorti également la
même année je sais pas si ça va être
bien mais en tout cas c'est en français
il y a le caste vocal de la série de
2002 dans les cinématiques le jeu est
plutôt beau dans l'endroit qui sert de
lobby ok il reste juste avant le
gameplay et
[Musique]
bizarre les traditions de la scène
patoune bon alors après je vais pas trop
critiquer le patunage à cette période là
du jeu vidéo c'était un truc de base
dans presque tous les jeux en fait une
astuce un peu cheap de Level Designer
pour montrer la voie aux joueurs et
surtout leur donner le sentiment
d'avancer et de ne pas bloquer oh
regardez ça brille ça bouge ça fait du
bruit mon cerveau est stimulé j'ai ma
base de deux familles alors ça c'était
un jeu correct un jeu auquel je pourrais
supporter de jouer éventuellement mais
est-ce qu'on pourrait peut-être aller
au-delà est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir un
jeu où j'aurais envie de jouer scoubidou
et le livre des ténèbres un jeu qui
s'inspire largement d'autres bons jeux
comme Luigi's Mansion on alterne entre
Sami et Scooby les gameplay sont
différents il y a de la furtivité des
fois il y a de l'action les bruitages
les voix tout est respecté il y a des
idées originales pour alterner entre les
personnages il y a des idées de mise en
scène avec différents axes de caméra il
y a pas de patoon oh mon dieu est-ce que
je vais le dire je crois que je
je suis en train de m'amuser je crois
que je passe un moment agréable le jeu
et comment on dit déjà c'est bien c'est
ça peut-être qu'il y a un monde où je
suis pas tout le temps obligé de jouer à
des jeux pourri peut-être que je
pourrais juste enlever ça et même
les amis j'ai une idée ah bah c'est pas
trop tôt laissez-moi vous expliquer
voilà mon plan
[Musique]
et voilà le travail
et à quel moment une cabane à oiseaux va
nous permettre de capturer un fantôme
pas de panique on fait comme d'habitude
Sami et Scooby vous servez d'appât et
vous ramenez le fantôme jusqu'à nous
tu le ferais pour un Scooby cuit non
hors de question
[Musique]
je suis pas un chien ça marche plus
trois scoubidous et un petit sachet de
cocaïne
[Musique]
allez allez viens là sale fantôme
viens pas trop vite non plus et nous on
doit faire quoi au juste Daphné vera
vous deux vous faites exactement comme
d'habitude
[Musique]
et pour finir la cerise sur le clou du
gâteau final Bou banane
qui traîne ça alors
c'est pas le musée de ta mère ici
et bien les amis voyons qui se cachait
derrière ce masque
Batman
Fred
j'en étais sûr oui c'était moi je
sentais que l'équipe avait besoin d'une
véritable affaire pour se remotiver
c'est pour ça que j'ai inventé toute
cette histoire donc le de Daphné qui est
en réalité mort depuis des mois pardon
[Musique]
tout ce random
Fred Fred attendez quoi oui
effectivement tout ça n'était que
montage et en réalité je voulais faire
fermer le musée pour faire construire un
musée par-dessus exactement oui
effectivement nous n'avons aucun
problème de fantôme dans ce musée
seulement une araignée géante qui bloque
la cantine
mais et les gars qui étaient déguisés en
bloc de Tetris et tous les trucs
bizarres qu'on a vu avec Scooby il y a
une explication très simple en fait il
s'agit
nous on te suit partout on va résoudre
ce mystère vis-à-vis d'après tout
conduisent à toi mon chou bonheur
où es-tu Scooby-Doo partout quoi de
neufs
pas de répit il faut trouver d'autres
indices
[Musique]
au bout de la vie quoi dans scoubidou
nous on te suit partout tu vas résoudre
ce mystère les indices après tout
conduise à toi mon chou [ __ ]
t'oublie tout dit
[Musique]